the communication internet is something
that's ubiquitous and we're using it 24
hours a day all of us have our cell
phones and our desktop computers and
we're generating information in the form
of audio video and text and we're
sharing it with friends we're sharing it
with the world
and in a communication network that's
designed to be distributed collaborative
and that favors peer-to-peer production
now that communication Internet's
converging with this very nascent energy
internet where we're now able to
generate our own green electricity
distributed collaborative peer-to-peer
and share it with the help of the
communication internet we create an
energy internet a transmission lines
become an Internet and now the third
component we are just beginning to see
the first glimpse of an automated
transport and logistics internet and
then the whole package is complete right
now logistics is a pretty inefficient
business if you take a look across the
United States like other countries and
you look at a truck on the road
sometimes those trucks are empty they're
dead heading back they've taken their
cargo and then there's nothing on the
trip back or they only have 20 or 30
percent of that truck filled right now
our logistics system is not coordinated
into a network there are thousands of
warehouses and distribution centers but
every company usually has only 5 or 10
of these warehouses somewhere in the
country so they have to take their their
trains or their trucks all the way to
where their handful of centers are but
what would happen if all the thousands
of warehouses and distribution centers
privately owned came together in a
cooperative network so if you're General
Electric or Walmart or wherever or a pro
a small prosumer small and medium-sized
company you would have access to any one
of those warehouses when they have
surplus space and you can move your
transport only where you needed it in
real time instead of going to a few
centralized warehouses across 3,000
miles but to do that you'd have to have
common protocols where everything is
standardized so you could get your
packages through in the same containers
with radio
recognition technology like Federal
Express has so you know where your your
Freight is in your package at any given
moment on the supply chain and then
we're now starting to move toward
driverless vehicles they'll be in mass
production within five to ten years
everywhere
according to six major auto companies
and so we'll be able to have a transport
system where we power our vehicles from
energy from our energy internet and will
power our electric vehicles and fuel
cell cars trucks and buses powered by
hydrogen all of that from our energy
internet at near zero marginal cost
transport that's already here in parts
of Europe we now have electric vehicles
fuel cell vehicles powered wouldn't with
energy that's near zero marginal cost in
a few years they'll be driverless
reducing the cost even further and so
this transport logistics internet is
connecting with the energy internet and
the communication internet which
provides the data one system it is a
game changer it is one of the great
technology revolutions in history it's
going to change our entire way of life
every single person what it mainly means
is it's the democratization of
everything this means in millions of
people and soon billions of people
they're not going to have to rely on the
goodwill of a handful of globally
integrated large vertically integrated
companies for the main stuff of life
we've now freed ourselves with
information to zero are near zero
marginal cost millions of us are
producing and sharing with each other
and we now have the first early adopters
that are now producing their own green
electricity of near zero marginal cost
millions of them already and we're just
starting to see a transport and
logistics internet that could get us to
near zero marginal cost this is the
democratization of everything and it's
going to change the economic model
you